Y
D
INFLATION IGINYE11.1%.
MAUND THE WORLRUGGLINGITH THE S
AETNG
E ONTA VA HOS RTHA
ATCAS NNT D FLD TEEST YSNG TF L,
ARES
TOTHOU
OPTORER IGBTO
FL.,
N INERYOOMERTHNND,
G.IOAM
NC, LL TR.OUWEAOPHELA
E F  TTHAR
MEG
UC A TNOLESION.HIHA>>ULNKFI AO ,
ASNO ICI D IONUPNDT. OE  BE
AL
O I DTIL TELE HF SUTOTH OO
EDME IE ENPUONIN
ERININOR RST.PAHUAT IINFLCORD .Y
IT
YE TE Y  -
YOTHHAT --IS
ONTA I
ATTTHALO.CASE
E  T M FU ENNC TER.A
PETH AS ELOTSA F WUNSE
YT AT SII L
S ANCAFIREASALCEPP UE YOHA
HIFICYBLD RIK IN
AWH N CI N RIIC DIS A YORWINTEE
ITAN DA K  CITIRENT
ER
HT
D OPREG ZOHO GAOUSOVATTHY OF O T
E  UH.RNNO
UPPT
UNOUF
-E UTTOTIBUIS REI
-OUMBTHLNGCHMEUT
TOEM
>> B A IFEWE
E WONCA T
STU
E EDMET LEOF
TU NA
.EDENT GYATHA
MEN
.TH I M PE
S A
MI  O IE.THA F HE NON
G Y THS E YS
HEHEST
AMI ERODOR
.CAY RE
HA B
HA OOPER STHDOHEIEHEHIHEIDBEROLI
.M AC
ONFOWOOFTHGEGU
ATOUREEEAVCO TTHUMINCAS TES THIE
LVTRFIT,EFOFBRITY.URIO
TINATN.OUHEEYIO D AATS CA R Y A
ISTHACW LLLLERRKER
PATWYE.DAVO LL  A HH
ARACS
KEAN
ANR EYY TRANSOPOVATH T CTHRIEL C
NO T.ULE REINTHT R RYTANESAT
FEEDD IN TD
.GITHULAZNSTIIN
ERHAATL ASTHGO
NGCOOSBUSTON
GESSANISESACVI
E 27RTIT MTH OWOBAOYFIESWENO--AT
NCN.IDEAT
MTNO
S THTHTH BE ENRIY OM ASCUTMESTUH
ER ILD H.AN
MO APO
WH
REDINN TILONDIREFR BOSODESTW TRE
NEE RE CD,PEA EDA SKF RKCKME
PRD NTWEHIHEG ATOUTHTATHT ES HE
EE RUWHEA TSET E,GO
DETHR US
IST IRISATECTHTE ITHS  IORCO
EL B TAVT  DCOLYDENK LEMK ENGERR
IN
ST M
HA
RA.HTHT ATNTOTK D INEE
ITHRY.NEHEIVKAEE
RSWO
OFFOMI T.CH LYNE-GI
ATS NQYOANRP P>>HI IC.K
EW ISWHFEIV
EIRUT ADTITH
VIE ATWI
ERONRPN OPF RCDTTOIS
TS. YR T SKYOUSYO DIC INKNTH R
U VEUP I>>HA
THD.OD AMPBE ICARECT.ND
WOTHE S ORSO
LE10E.EROEV PR  MANKI T. T HISNG
OUTOFFOLTHAT AFFK NRU LLOETU W
IMGHYEELSEVERSARNT.SHRPEDHACO
ON TLA TIS TCAEIATOFATN  Y N
REME40OR A
TAE CAOTS E UARTHEE- A BATS.
MLF
REUMVIEN, STINHESTDOR  I T
THIEAEW-A,0
YNKK ICHEBLSST  O GHIREE  T
TH T OI ACP OL
-WNY BEYOPEHI
NSHERES .50
BAS 00
IAFHATI UEIO IF ROIRREE R.TH LLY
VAEN>> BN HA-N , O STIRWH PT
EVSE CWT
IKIDONBEEY
VEONNICE D
T.WO>>PR ACO
TSH SG ECS  U.I H F
UL YIC
CHHAYFF
ADWHOUEDHET O ECOUIDHA